so we're asked to graph f of x is equal
to 2 times the absolute value of x plus
plus 2. and what they've already graphed
for us this right over here this is the
graph of y is equal to the absolute
value of x so let's do this through a
series of transformations so the next
thing i want to graph
let's see if we can graph
y
y is equal to the absolute value of x
plus 3.
now in previous videos we have talked
about it if you replace your x with an x
plus 3 this is going to shift your graph
to the left by 3. you could view this as
the same thing as y is equal to the
absolute value of x minus
negative three and whatever you are
subtracting from this x that is how much
you are shifting it so you're going to
shift it three to the left and we're
gonna do that right now and then we're
just gonna confirm that it matches up
that it makes sense
so let's first graph that and get my
ruler tool here so if we shift 3 to the
left it's going to look something like
it's going to look something like this
so on that
when whatever we have inside the
absolute value sign is positive we're
going to get essentially this slope of
one and whenever
we have inside the absolute value sign
is negative we're going to have a slope
of essentially negative 1.
so it's going to look
it's going to look like that
and let's confirm whether this actually
makes sense
below
x equals negative 3. for x values less
than negative 3
what we're going to have here is this
inside of the absolute value sign
is going to be negative and so then
we're going to take its opposite value
and so that makes sense that's why you
have this downward line right over here
now for
x is greater than negative 3 when you
add 3 to it you're going to get a
positive value and so that's why you
have this upward sloping line right over
here and at x equals negative three you
have zero inside the absolute value sign
just as if you didn't shift it you would
have had zero inside the absolute value
sign at x equals zero so hopefully that
makes a little bit more intuitive sense
of why if you replace x if you replace x
with x plus three and this isn't just
true of absolute value functions this is
true of any function if you replace x
with x plus three you're going to shift
3 to the left
all right now let's keep building
now let's see if we can graph
y is equal to 2 times the absolute value
of x plus 3.
so what this is essentially going to do
is multiply the slopes by a factor
of 2. it's going to stretch it
vertically by a factor of 2.
so
for x values greater than negative three
instead of having a slope of one you're
gonna have a slope of two so let me get
my ruler out again and see if i can draw
that
so
let me put that there
and then
so here instead of a slope of 1 i'm
going to have a slope of
2. let me draw that
it's going to look like that right over
there
and then
instead of having a slope of negative 1
for values less than x equals negative 3
i'm going to have a slope of
negative 2.
let me draw that right over there
so that is the graph of y is equal to 2
times the absolute value of x plus 3.
and now to get to the f of x that we
care about we now need to add this 2.
so now i want to graph and we're in the
home stretch i want to graph y is equal
to 2 times the absolute value of x plus
plus 2.
well whatever y value i was getting for
this orange function i now want to add 2
to it so this is just going to shift it
up vertically by 2.
so
instead of so this is going to be
shifted up by two this is going to be
shifted
the every point is going to be shifted
up by two or you can think about
shifting up the entire graph by two here
in the orange function whatever y value
i got for the black function i'm going
to have to get 2 more than that and so
it's going to look
it's going to look like this
so let me see i'm shifting it up by 2.
so for x less than negative three it'll
look like that
and for x
greater than negative three
it is
going to look like
it is going to look like
that
and there you have it
this
is the graph of y or f of x is equal to
2 times the absolute value of x plus 3
plus 2. and you could have done it in
different ways you could have shifted up
2 first
then you could have
multiplied by a factor of two and then
you could have shifted and then so you
could have moved up two first then you
could have multiplied by a factor two
then you could have shifted left by
three or you could have multiplied by a
factor of 2 first shifted up 2 and then
shifted over so there's multiple there's
three transformations going up here this
is an
this is a let me color them all so this
right over here tells me
this over here says hey shift left
shift
left
by
three
this
told us stretch vertically by two
or essentially multiply the slope by 2
stretch
vert
by 2 and then that last piece says shift
up by 2
shift
up
by 2 which gives us our final result for
f x